développement innovation embauche les
entreprises de saint quentin en yvelines
peuvent maintenant faire appel au
financement participatif pour mener à
bien leurs projets particuliers ou
professionnels deviennent alors acteurs
de l'économie locale des financeurs sont
vous et moi si vous avez 1000 5000
euros à placer plutôt que de le mettre
sur un livret a dont vous savez qu'il
vous rapportera pas grand chose vous
pouvez aller sur le site voir si un
projet vous séduit il ya deux outils
soient des prêts donc vous prêter sous
forme d'investissements soit vous
rentrez au capital et vous devenez
actionnaire de cette entreprise
le dispositif s'adresse aux entreprises
du territoire
immatriculée au registre du commerce et
des sociétés pour le mettre en place
la communauté d'agglomération a créé un
partenariat avec l'entreprise kiosque to
invest
ça va de soi toutes les start up pme
toutes les structures corps et des
besoins de financement pour financer
leur développement leur croissance qui
auraient un besoin donc en fonds propres
entre 100000 euros et 2 min ou cinq les
seules contraintes on va dire juridique
c'est que la société soit et ça ou ss ou
en mesure de le devenir et ensuite et
qu'elle ait réalisé un premier chiffre
d'affaires ou alors une promesse
première promesse de chiffre d'affaires
pour déposer votre projet ou allez les
découvrir
rendez vous sur le site de sky invest
depuis sa création il ya quelques mois
la plateforme a déjà recueilli trois
demandes de financement les projets sont
actuellement en cours de validation